line AC is tangent to circle o at Point
C so this is line AC tangent to circle o
at Point C what is the length of segment
AC what is this distance right over here
between point a and Point C I encourage
you now to pause this video and try this
out on your own so I'm assuming you've
given a go at it so the key thing to
realize here if since AC is tangent to
the circle at Point C that means it's
going to be perpendicular to the radius
between the center of the circle and
Point C so this right over here is a
right right angle and the reason why
that is useful is now we know that
triangle a OC is a right triangle so we
could use if we know two of its sides we
could use the Pythagorean theorem to
figure out the third now we clearly know
Oh see now Oh a we don't know the entire
side they only give us that a B is equal
to two but the thing that might jump out
at your in your mind is OB is a radius
OB is a radius it's going to be the same
length as any radius so this is going to
be three as well so the distance between
the center of the circle and a point on
the circle just like the distance
between o and C so this is going to be
three as well and so now we are able to
figure out that the hypotenuse of this
triangle has length 5 and so we need to
figure out what side the slot the length
of segment AC is so let's just call that
I don't know I'll call that I will call
that X X and so we know that x squared
plus 3 squared I'm just applying the
Pythagorean theorem here so plus 3
squared is going to be equal to the
length of the hypotenuse squared is
going to be equal to 5 squared and I
know this is the hypotenuse it's the
side opposite the 90 degree angle it's
the longest side of the right triangle
so x squared x squared plus 9 plus 9 is
equal to 25 is equal to 25 subtract 9
from both sides and you get
you get x squared is equal to 16 and so
it should jump out at you that X is
going to be equal to X is equal to 4 so
X is equal to 4
X is the same thing as the length of
segment AC so the length of segment AC
is 4